when you're in audit asking the right
questions will lead to right answers and
that will happen only if you know the
subject well Advanced executive program
in cyber security has not only helped me
become better in what I do but has also
paired the way to take on Senior
Management role with ease hey I'm
architation and I live in Chennai with
my wife and two kids I am currently
working with Standard Chartered Bank at
senior audit manager I've been a member
of cyber security audit team at my
company for past two years my role
demands me to manage and deal with
oddities on a daily basis I've been with
fintech for the past 19 years and things
have changed drastically over the years
there has been so much of advancement in
the way we use technology to conduct
cyber security audits so one needs to
keep learning so I thought why not a
course in cyber security I came across
simply learn course on cyber security in
association with triple it Bangalore so
I decided to take it I've been able to
manage or it is better by asking them
the right set of questions because now I
know certain things I am able to
highlight issues with Oddities in front
of Signal Management and take steps to
solve them I have to make at present
reports to various senior stakeholders
within information and cyber security
services including the CSO at my company
and I think I can do it in a much better
way now I have found that confidence in
myself I'm touching the city management
roles and the certification will really
help me there
simply learn also provided an
opportunity to do an internship with
npci towards the end the simply learn
team is very Cooperative they actually
postpone some classes due to Kobe 19. a
lot of platforms don't do that I would
like to say thanks to my family
especially my wife who was a pillar of
support to me I spend my time with my
kids
before you ask other questions ask
yourself how can I become better
I always do I think upskilling is the
answer